everybody no matter where you come from
has someone that they care about
we built an app that is a peer-to-peer
safety network that allows people to
select companions from their contact
book to watch them walk home safely and
if they ever feel nervous or unsafe they
can notify you within three tabs when we
chose Google Maps for the foundation of
our app it was something that developers
trusted but the consumer also trusted we
want to build something that changes the
way people live and improves their life
methane is a huge global threat to all
of our ecosystems and our health it
affects everything we are and we do and
so I feel really compelled day to day to
like get up and try to fix the problem
in the best most impactful way that I
can
what we've done is put methane sensors
on a number of Street View cars to map
and measure methane levels coming from
hundreds of U streets
the maps that we've created with the
help of the API have really made this
data visible in a way that it's never
been before
there's nothing getting you ready for
being homeless all of a sudden
everything we take for granted is taken
away and we find ourselves facie
sleeping in the streets I think it's my
duty as a person that a key lived the
experience to give back and actually
help others in Australia one in 200
people are homeless but 80% of them have
got a smartphone of some kind so there's
a tremendous opportunity to get
information into their hands the whole
point of our application is to help our
users find their way to the services
that they need using the Google Maps API
means that we can give people the
information they need to make a decision
there's no sign post signs we get
through this we get makers it doesn't
happen
and forgiveness for somebody who's sill
homeless to actually help them become
whole and they raise negative